joining me now is brian dean right
former CIA officer and congressman devon
Nunez ranking member of the House in
telemedicine why is all of this
happening now and why the freak out
among the never Trump errs and the left
well I can tell you when it was supposed
to start it was supposed to start when
general Flynn came in as National
Security Advisor I know from my
discussions with him I served on the
transition team that he thought that the
bureaucracy in in Washington DC across
all the Intel agencies was way too big
and he thought it should be shrunk down
and that the the DNI wear ambassador
Grinnell is going that is a bureaucracy
that was supposed to be a strategic
planning arm one of its only goals was
to try to fix the process by which you
get security clearances and here we are
nearly two decades later that's the one
thing they haven't fixed and all they
have done is got larger and larger and
larger so Republicans actually believe
that the DNI does need to be downsized
but I do have to say Laura just so I'm
perfectly clear I'm not aware of any
black lists that have been created yeah
in Washington that sounds like a fake
news story of some kind but I think the
overall objective of reducing the size
of these agencies is a good one
the more people we have out on the field
the much better we are I just love this
idea that the president should actively
wat recruit people who work against his
agenda and have them populate his
administration this is crazytown stuff I
mean the idea that you would have people
who were burrowed in to work against
your administration's priorities is
lunacy no one would put up with that
Brian remember that big media bombshell
in the alleged Russia collusion last
week well now even CNN is reporting it
was bogus the senior DNI official shelby
pearson told lawmakers on the house
Intel committee that Russia's
interfering the twenty20 election with
the goal of helping trump the
intelligence doesn't say that though one
senior national security official told
CNN a more reasonable interpretation of
the Intel is not that they have a
preference it's a step short of that
it's more that they understand the
president someone they can work with
that he's a deal maker so Brian how
would an Intel briefer who's described
as someone who has a reputation of being
injudicious with her words get to do a
briefing such as this that set off this
chain reaction
well when the intelligence community
sends the staffer to the hill apparently
they're not sending us their best so
look we have one of two problems here
with this this this person we've got
somebody who's either incompetent which
isn't really reassuring or we have
somebody who was a partisan hack which
is also deeply alarming or perhaps bolt
so but let's look at those two pieces
she was a career satellite imagery
specialist why then DNI coats selected
her for this role in any depth of
political analysis the nuanced necessary
for that I don't know it's shocking but
yet we can't also say can we that she
didn't have any particular political
bias because we know that the
whistleblower of course had political
bias multiple of them actually we also
know that James Comey was leaking to
achieve his partisan goals so we can't
say to the American people that is the
intelligence community that there was
nothing nefarious there and to me is a
former intelligence officer that's
actually the most alarming and sad part
of this story right yes it's bad what
happened but it's the fact that you were
you were I can't have faith in the
intelligence community yet we have so
many problems so many enemies that we
have to to tackle and find and and
neutralize and how do we do that has the
president do that if you can't have
faith that his intelligence community is
on his side and on the side of the
American people instead doing what they
want to do for their own forces to hire
more people like Shelby Pearson to give
really bad briefings that set off this
reaction that's what he's supposed to do
congressman Nunez congressman breaking
tonight this is about you House
Republicans considering criminal
referrals against Muller prosecutors
you're looking into those 302s those
infamous 302s how this whole deal
started what can you tell us tonight
because people want accountability here
so slowly but surely some of the reports
are being declassified so about a few
weeks
I actually mentioned this on a couple of
the shows that we were going through
those reports and then beginning to
match them up to the molar indictments
and the molar recommendations for
prosecutions and one of the things that
we found and Lee Smith has done some
great reporting on this and he has a
story out today on it is that is that
remember the whole story that
Papadopoulos needed to be really treated
badly and sentenced to some time because
he really stopped the FBI from being
able to find joseph Mifsud after all
that well it is if that's not true
that's not what the 302 say the 302 is
actually say that Papadopoulos was
actually trying to help the FBI and
they're the ones who said that Mifsud
was going to be in the united states and
so if the lawyers that wrote that to the
to the court into the recommendation to
the court they need to be held
accountable
so we're scrubbing through all of these
302s and we will be making some type of
criminal referral perhaps attorney
general bar is appointed in a US
Attorney out of Missouri we'll see
exactly what that US attorney is looking
at but it's not okay to lie to a federal
judge especially about something so
serious as somebody who's going to be
indicted to serve prison time
now as Bryan said as you've said so many
times and you've both written spoken
about this we need to be able to trust
our Intel we have it should not be
political and our FBI the way it
proceeds has to be fair across the board
without regard to party politics that's
all the president's asking for he's not
asking for special treatment gentlemen
you're both fantastic we really
appreciate you tonight thanks so much